rentrée chargée pour general electric
après la pause estivale l'intersyndicale
reprend le combat déterminé à sauver un
maximum d'emplois
le plan de 792 suppressions de postes
lui est toujours d'actualité
un paradoxe car depuis le début de
l'année le marché mondial des turbines à
gaz est en pleine reprise
le site de belfort a même du mal à
honorer ses commandes d'un côté general
electric nous dit à nous rabâche depuis
un an que le marché est bas raison pour
laquelle il faut réorganiser
l'entreprise on se rend compte
aujourd'hui dans nos ateliers que
l'activité est là est pire que ça on
sera pas en mesure de donner les
commandes on sera pas en mesure de
sortir nos turbines à gaz en temps en
heure du fait de cette charge de travail
un comité de suivi du dossier est prévu
ce mercredi à bercy avec bruno le maire
les syndicats n'y sont pas conviés mais
ils ont transmis au cabinet du ministre
des documents prouvant que jean a pas
respecté le contrat signé avec l'état
français lors du rachat de la branche
énergie d'alstom en 2014
nous nous proposons de travailler sur un
projet alternatif ou belfort a toute sa
place et nous ce qu'on revendique on
auprès du gouvernement c'est qu'ils
obtiennent auprès de j que belfort
produisent un son de décision et ça
c'est conforme à l'accord s'il ne le
faisait pas nous on est prêt à porter
plainte contre le gouvernement qu'il
faut pas respecter l'accord nous sommes
prêts la plainte était prête non plus
qu'à appuyer sur le bouton
en parallèle l'intersyndicale milite
pour un plan de diversification des
activités
une diversification qui semble enfin se
dessiner le site de belfort vient de se
lancer dans la fabrication des lettes
deux réacteurs pour l'aéronautique
une activité qui emploie pour l'instant
une quinzaine de personnes